ja es gibt Wählerinnen und Wähler der
AFD die rechtsradikal sind die sie auch
deswegen wählen aber nach allem was wir
sehen und wissen ist es eher der
kleinere Teil zumal bei diesen
Prozentwerten wenn man Leuten die der
Meinung sind Migration sollte begrenzt
sein weil wenn ich unendlich leisten
können wenn man Leuten die der Meinung
sind
zum Beispiel eben dass es zwei
biologische Geschlechter gibt wenn man
Leuten die der Meinung sind sie möchten
in Ihrer Nachbarschaft keine die Tipp
Moschee haben aus der Türkei finanziert
wenn man den Leuten sagt dass sie recht
sind
dann kann es passieren dass ein Teil von
denen sagt ja dann werde ich halt recht
und das glaube ich ist auch die Frage
wie wir politische Auseinandersetzung
machen da bin eine politische
Auseinandersetzung in der Sache machen
die das Argument sucht die sich auch in
der Sache reibt oder ob wir eine
politische Auseinandersetzung haben und
ich finde die haben wir zu oft die ganz
schnell im emotionalen im moralischen
ist und am Ende eben ganz schnell
zuordnet
[Musik]